England star Raheem Sterling was back at
his mansion on an exclusive private
estate residents here have the latest
and best security systems but that
didn't stop burglars raiding his home
and stealing jewelry watches and other
valuables
at the time Sterling was in Qatar
playing in the early World Cup group
games his fiancee and their two children
were with him criminals knew that the
famous ones who show on television I
know they're not going to be at home the
property is likely to be unoccupied
empty families tend to go away on big
tournaments of them like the World Cup
so the premises is like to be an
occupied hence it's it's easy for the
criminals to Target it and they know
exactly where they live as well
last year the empty home of Sterling's
Chelsea teammate Rhys James was burgled
an Arsenal player Gabrielle fought off
car thieves in his own garage
Sterling left his England colleagues
training without him the player's
Representatives claimed his family had
been the victims of an armed robbery
Sterling's teammates were preparing for
Saturday's quarter-final against France
he wished us the best you know yesterday
as he was as he was going back and yeah
I've messaged him and hopefully he'll
get back to me later I just hope he's
okay him and his family
Surrey police said in a statement at
this time it remains unclear on which
dates the property was stolen and
establishing this forms a key part of
our investigation inquiries until the
full circumstances remain ongoing and
officers will look at all available
evidence including any CCTV
opportunities there are no reports of
any threats of violence linked to this
incident it is an intrusion into your
very Central sense of well-being so it
does have a massive psychological impact
on individuals no matter how little is
taken and no matter how it may be a
completely non-violent invasion of the
home
it's not the first time Sterling has
been targeted when he played for
Manchester City burglars tried to break
into his Cheshire Mansion but was scared
away when an alarm went off the burglars
were eventually caught after raiding the
homes of other wealthy football figures
it's not known if Sterling will rejoin
the England team
Martin brunt Sky News Surrey